chers collègues bonjour à vous monsieur
baptiste bonjour c'est une configuration
tout à fait nouvelle pour les uns et les
autres nous sommes réunis donc ce matin
en application de l'article 13 de la
constitution pour vous auditionné
monsieur philippe baptiste puisque vous
êtes candidat proposé aux fonctions de
président du conseil d'administration du
cnes donc je vous souhaite la bienvenue
dans notre devant notre commission
l'article 13 je le rappelle pour mes
collègues de la constitution dispose que
pour certaines nominations des emplois
ou fonctions en raison de leur
importance pour la vie économique et
sociale de la nation le pouvoir de
nomination du président de la république
ne peut s'exercer qu'après avis public
de la commission compétente de chacune
des assemblées il ne peut procéder à une
nomination lorsque l'addition des votes
négatifs dans chaque commission
représente au moins trois cinquièmes des
suffrages exprimés au sein des
commissions compétentes de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
je rappelle que dans ce cadre aucune
délégation de vote n'est autorisé pas
plus que le vote par visioconférence
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce matin
du nous réunissons dans cet hémicycle de
façon totalement inhabituel et donc
j'invite chacun d'entre vous à rester
jusqu'à la fin de l'audition pour
procéder au vote
voilà la commission des affaires
économiques de l'assemblée nationale
vous auditionnant également à 11h ce
matin nous procéderont au dépouillement
à l'issue de votre seconde il
audition par dont le dépouillement sera
effectué par deux scrutateurs et aura
lieu simultanément dans les deux
chambres
conformément à l'article 5 de
l'ordonnancé du 17 novembre 1958
voilà une fois ses prévisions effectuées
j'en viens au fond du sujet bien sûr le
cnes est un établissement public à
caractère industriel et commercial qui a
plusieurs objectifs il célèbre cette
année ses 60 ans d'existence et il
intervient dans cinq domaines que je
vais vous rappeler l'accès à l'espace
via le développement des lanceurs
européens le soutien aux sciences pour
améliorer notre connaissance de
l'univers
et notre capacité à explorer l'espace
l'observation de la terre et le recueil
des données et le développement des
satellites pour permettre des
télécommunications à haut débit et enfin
la mise en oeuvre et c'est pas le peu de
la stratégie spatiale de la défense j'en
viens au candidat qui est devant nous
que je remercie d'être là proposé par le
président de la république monsieur
philippe baptiste vous êtes ingénieur en
chef des mines
titulaire d'un doctorat en informatique
vous débutez en 99 une carrière
scientifique au cnrs au sein de laquelle
vous effectuez une grande partie de
votre parcours professionnel
à compter de 2013 votre parcours
professionnel se diversifie davantage et
vous occuper des fonctions au sein de
l'administration du cnrs puis de total
en 2010 est vous êtes nommé directeur de
cabinet de madame frédéric vidal
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et de l'innovation et de
l'espace avant de rejoindre le cabinet
du premier ministre en 2019
enfin depuis le mois de novembre 2020
vous occupez un poste à responsabilité
au sein de la vision data sayans du
cabinet de conseil bcg si votre parcours
est exemplaire il ne reste pas moins que
la presse qualifie d' atypique et de
rupture au regard des fonctions pour
lesquelles vous êtes pressenti monsieur
baptiste vous aurez donc lors de cette
audition à défendre votre candidature a
présenté naturellement vos motivations
et votre projet bien sûr pour le cnes
premièrement je souhaiterais que vous
nous présenter votre candidature vos
motivations six candidats étaient
pressentis la presse ayant fait état des
désaccords du gouvernement sur le sujet
le ministre de l'économie des finances
et de la relance auquel je ne fais
naturellement pas offense avait une
préférence pour un candidat avec une
expérience significative dans le domaine
spatial et industriels soutenaient
plutôt la candidature de l'ancien
directeur spatiale d'airbus ou celle du
pdg d'arianespace
au contraire la ministre des armées et
c'est bien naturel avait une préférence
pour des candidats issus de la dgr dans
ce contexte pour ces vous être le
candidat du consensus de l' équilibre
malgré votre finalement peu d'expérience
dans le domaine spatial si ce n'est au
cabinet et quels seraient les avantages
de votre parcours professionnel pour le
cnes deuxièmement vous pourrez nous dire
qu'elle
guerre vous portez sur l'action du cnes
durant ces dernières années puisque la
priorité avait été donnée au lanceur
européen
or sur ce point le développement
d'offres commerciales concurrentielle
notamment spe 6 l'arrivée sur le marché
de lanceurs institutionnels et
commerciaux en chine en russie en inde
ont permis de diminuer le coût d'accès à
l'espace cette situation menace
aujourd'hui la compétitivité des
lanceurs européens notamment celle
d'ariane 6 qui m'est chère dont le
lancement est prévu pour le deuxième
trimestre 2022 dans ce contexte quelle
serait votre stratégie pour soutenir le
lancement d'ariane 6 préserver la
compétitivité des lanceurs européens et
pensez vous que le développement d'une
nouvelle génération de lanceurs ariane
ex soit toujours pertinent et qu'il ne
faudrait pas plutôt investir dans les
phares me lanceur réutilisables
troisièmement vous pourrez justement
nous parler des orientations et des
mesures que vous souhaitez prendre pour
garantir l'unité européenne en matière
spatiale aujourd'hui qui semble menacé
par quelques difficultés et des
ambitions nationales
le projet d'alliance européenne les
lanceurs souhaitait pas retirer bretons
sont aujourd'hui tous et ou en tout cas
compromis l'allemagne adopte une vision
de plus en plus minimaliste de la
coopération européenne sur ces sujets
travailler au développement de ses
propres lanceur de plus petites diminue
de plus petites dimensions pardon dans
cette perspective l'allemagne ambitionne
même de créer son propre port spatial
dans le nord du pays
concurrents sans évidemment kourou dans
ce contexte quel rôle le cnes
pourrait-il jouer pour maintenir l'unité
européenne
quatrièmement vous pouvez nous exposer
pourrait nous exploser votre stratégie
de soutien à l'industrie spatiale cette
fois-ci française
je me permets de rappeler la sensibilité
des sénateurs de notre commission la
nécessité bien sûr de cette filière
d'excellence viable et rentable
or aujourd'hui pour un budget annuel
d'environ 2 8 milliards d'euros la
moitié des crédits alloués au cnes soit
un milliard quatre sont réservés à la
gent spatiale européenne au titre de la
contribution tandis que le soutien à
l'industrie spatiale française
financées par les crédits
d'investissements d'avenir
quelles sont les principales
orientations mesure que vous pourriez
prendre afin d'assurer un financement
pérenne de l'industrie spatiale
française voilà ensuite vous pourrez
nous nous parlait peut-être rapidement
dès votre point de vue sur les
développements des nouvelles
applications du spatial qui pourrait
être source de développement
voilà monsieur baptiste je vous cède la
parole pour un propos liminaire et
apporter les premiers éléments de
réponse à ces questions et bien sûr je
laisserai les commissaires vous posez
des questions rapidement donnant la
priorité aux membres s'étant déjà
inscrits préalablement je rappelle à mes
collègues que la boucle wales ap l'outil
idoine
ce matin parce que malheureusement je
leur tourner le dos voilà monsieur
bâtisse ne vous écoute on merci merci
madame mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie de me
recevoir pour présenter à la fois ma
candidature et mon projet pour le pour
le cnes j'essaierai de répondre à
travers mon propos liminaire un certain
nombre des questions que vous avez
soulevé
je crois que le spatial est devenu
aujourd'hui un enjeu absolument
essentiel pour les télécommunications
pour nos industries pour l'observation
de la terre pour le climat pour la
science pour la défense pour la sécurité
intérieure et les géants du numérique
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde ne s'y
sont pas trompés ils investissent
massivement les états eux aussi
accroître leurs efforts par tous dans ce
monde qui change à très grande vitesse
les acteurs français et des acteurs
européens doivent relever des défis qui
sont des défis considérables mais aussi
saisir de nouvelles opportunités et
cette audition donc l occasion de vous
présenter quelques grandes en jeu que je
crois pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
rapidement
avant cela permettez moi de saluer le
travail qui a été mené par jean yves le
gall actuel président du cnes touton ses
deux mandats
avec ses prédécesseurs jean yves a
contribué à faire du cnes d'un des
joyaux technologique du pays
il a soutenu efficacement nos champions
industriels l'industrie française des
télécommunications par satellite par
exemple avec airbus et thales et leurs
équipementiers représente 60% du marché
mondial c'est un très grand succès cette
réussite témoigne entre autres de la
pertinence des choix effectués depuis de
nombreuses années par l'état le cnes et
l'ensemble de l'industrie sur ses
programmes de r&d jean yves le gall a
aussi su faire rayonner la science et la
technologie en dehors de nos frontières
et je tiens le sel je voudrais enfin
aussi très brièvement cité son
prédécesseur yannick d'escatha grand
serviteur de l'état et grands
industriels qui a profondément rénové le
cnes je vais dire quelques mots sur mon
parcours professionnel avant de
présenter les axes stratégiques
ingénieurs et chercheurs j'ai consacré
ma carrière à la science et à la
technologie et à leurs applications
la science nous permet de comprendre un
monde qui change chaque jour la vie des
hommes
elle est un moteur d'un progrès auquel
je suis profondément attaché après un
master en grande bretagne un débat en
france j'ai choisi de faire de la
recherche en optimisation combinatoire
et en mathématiques discrète un domaine
à la frontière entre l'informatique les
mathématiques et l'intelligence
artificielle si vous validez ma
nomination à la tête du cnes je ne serai
pas le premier informaticiens
mathématicien tête de cet organisme
j'inscrirai humblement mais pas dans
ceux de jacques louis lions c'est alain
bensoussan de très très bons
scientifiques et deux illustres
président du cnes ingénieurs dans un
groupe de btp j'ai commencé mon doctorat
en travaillant sur des problèmes
relativement appliquée de r&d et je me
suis progressivement intéressés à des
problèmes beaucoup plus fondamentaux
d'algorithmique étudié depuis longtemps
et le cheminement même fin ma démarche
en fait en passant de l'appliquer
chose plus théorique m'a permis
d'apporter des solutions nouvelles à ses
problèmes difficiles
ce premier aller-retour entre
applications et théorie a profondément
marqué l'ensemble de ma carrière
académique et industriel j'ai rejoint le
cnrs j'ai été professeur chargé de cours
à l'école polytechnique pendant une
dizaine d'années et j'ai conduit de
front une activité académique
si on à mettre au meilleur niveau
international et en maintenant à
négocier à des problèmes industriels et
j'ai ainsi travaillé comme ingénieur
pour les chercheurs comme 'pourris' log
pour bouygues pour ibm aux états unis et
j'ai mené mon contrat de recherche avec
thales eurocontrol tdf ou microsoft
et donc j'ai été en contact avec des
secteurs industriels très variés
l'édition logicielle l'industrie des
semi conducteurs l'aéronautique le
contrôle aérien j'ai d'ailleurs aussi
travaillé sur un problème d'ordre de
lancement de prises de vues de
satellites il ya déjà quelques temps le
rapprochement déjà par là du secteur
spatial
et j'ai aussi créé un certain nombre de
start-up dans le domaine de l'énergie
je me suis progressivement investi dans
les activités de management de la
recherche son dirigeant mon laboratoire
alix puis l'un des dix instituts du cnrs
et enfin comme directeur général délégué
de ce grand organisme le cnrs est
d'ailleurs le premier partenaire du cnes
qui finance les personnels et les
laboratoires académiques qui portent des
projets spatiaux le spatial était une
composante importante aussi pour le cnrs
j'ai aussi été directeur scientifique de
total et après avoir réorganisé
l'ensemble de la r&d je suis devenu le
premier site you du groupe
cette nouvelle organisation a permis de
lancer des projets ambitieux autour du
stockage de carbone par exemple ces
dernières années enfin comme vous l'avez
mentionné madame la présidente j'étais
directeur de cabinet de frédéric vidal
puis puis
conseiller éducation enseignement chypre
recherche et innovation d'edouard
philippe et j'ai évidemment directement
suivi dans ses deux fonctions notre
politique spatiale pour résumer je crois
bénéficier d'une triple expérience dans
les champs industriels scientifiques et
technologiques
je crois aussi avoir acquis une solide
familiarité avec le fonctionnement de
l'état et avec le pilotage des grandes
institutions publiques je vais
maintenant vous présenter quelques axes
stratégiques pour le cnes en répondant
je crois un certain nombre de vos
questions le secteur spatial connaît
aujourd'hui un bouleversement et une
accélération inédit sous l'impulsion je
crois de trois facteurs le premier
facteur c'est une miniaturisation
croissante des satellites et une
réduction des temps de conception
d'industrialisation et développement le
deuxième facteur c'est la réduction des
coûts de fabrication et de lancement on
pourrait même dire une des coûts de
maintenance des lanceurs grâce en
particulier au succès du réutilisables
et le 3 agilité accrue de nouveaux
acteurs qui appliquent des méthodes qui
ont fait leurs preuves dans un domaine
que je connais bien qui est le numérique
mais aussi les hauts du domaine de
l'automobile par exemple
et ces trois facteurs lève
progressivement des barrières à l'entrée
des marchés spatiaux barrières qu'il ya
encore quelques années semblait quasi
infranchissable
ces nouveaux entrants amène des capitaux
mais pas que des capitaux aussi de
nouveaux modèles de r&d les nouveaux
modèles de commercialisation
et c'est un bouleversement profond ces
bouleversements sont autant de défis qui
doivent être relevés par la france et
ses partenaires
si notre organisation doit s'adapter la
france n'en reste pas moins une
puissance spatiale de premier plan le
cnes a développé un savoir faire reconnu
et satellite et français sont les cités
tout à l'heure parmi les champions
mondiaux
le centre de toulouse i d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup ariane 5 est un lanceur fiable
et robuste
ariane 6 saura capitaliser sur ses
succès j'en suis persuadé le csg est un
atout exceptionnel et les équipes de
scientifiques comme les instruments
français sont régulièrement sélectionné
pour participer aux grandes missions
internationales dans ce contexte à la
fois de défis mais aussi de force de
notre de notre écosystème
je voudrais aborder cinq enjeux
stratégiques qui me semble essentielle
pour le cnes demain le premier enjeu le
premier ange ou je crois ce sont les
données du spatial
la diminution des coûts de production
des données spatiales change
radicalement la chaîne de valeur que
nous connaissons les puissance capable
de produire de collecter de traiter de
mettre dans le cloud ces données pour
les fournir de nouveaux services aux
états aux entreprises et aux citoyens
vont posséder dans les années qui
viennent un avantage concurrentiel
absolument considérable amazon et
microsoft ont déjà lancé leur premier
service de groundation au service
alibaba atteste même concept avec des
entreprises chinoises et internationales
c'est un enjeu majeur pour les années
qui viennent le cnes qui a su prendre le
virage par exemple du calcul intensif
lors de la décennie précédente doit
préparer dès maintenant cette nouvelle
révolution numérique
il doit aider à faire émerger une
solution française et européenne
compétitive pas seul évidemment loin de
là mais en mobilisant des start up des
acteurs privés des acteurs
institutionnels du numérique
je crois profondément et je n'ai pas mis
au hasard évidemment cet enjeu en
première position à 7 à cette
convergence entre le monde du numérique
et le monde du spatial deuxièmement je
me semble-t-il qui est proche du premier
et sans doute c'est la question de
l'innovation et des relations avec les
industriels
avec la baisse des barrières à l'entrée
des applications spatiales la manière de
penser l'innovation doit aussi évoluer
les programmes de r&d qui associe r&d
qui associe pardon publics et privés sur
des temps longs restent absolument
essentiel loin de moi l'idée de les
remettre en question mais à côté de ces
programmes on ne peut que constater dans
le domaine du spatial comme dans
d'autres domaines que des ruptures
technologiques ou commercial viennent de
petites structures de start up qui par
leur capacité à prendre de très très
grands risques savent parfois à
s'aventurer là où serions pas allés
naturellement en utilisant aussi des
effets leviers des capitaux de divers le
cnes doit faciliter l'éclosion de ces
écosystèmes en répondant rapidement
positivement ou négativement et en
répondant rapidement aux sollicitations
en soutenant des projets par des apports
de technologie par des apports des
expertises en mobilisant des fonds
partenaires et en viabilité
ont des projets de startups par des
contrats publics quand c'est pertinent
ça me semble vraiment essentiel d'aller
dans cette direction de 2e 2e 2e partie
est toujours dans les dents la question
de l'innovation et des relations avec
les industriels
il faut aussi évidemment maintenir les
relations de confiance qui existe déjà
aujourd'hui avec nos petits et nos très
grands industriels du secteur
nous devons renforcer en permanence ses
relations de confiance et adapté je
crois que ce point est important de
méthodes de travail à la maturité
technologique des différents champs qui
sont couverts par ces différents
industriels
donc faut vraiment qu'on soit à l'écouté
de cet écosystème
troisième enjeu vous l'attendez et sans
doute c'est la question des lanceurs
ariane 6 le futur lanceur lourd européen
développé sous la responsabilité
d'ariane groupe devrait faire son
premier vol me 2022
il nous garantira un accès autonome et
pérenne à l'espace ariane 6 devra faire
face à une concurrence féroce de spe 6
pas que de ce pessimisme et de spe 6 le
falcon a déjà effectué plus de 100 vols
il a démontré l'intérêt économique du
réutilisables mais n'oublions pas que la
politique commerciale très aggressive
d'elon musk aujourd'hui ne repose pas
que sur cette insolente réussite
technologique et sur ce pari tout
d'abord la nasa n'oublions pas a conçu
les premières versions des moteurs
merlin formidable accélérateur du
programme spécial au space x bénéficie
de plus d'innombrables lancement
institutions qui permettent à notre
concurrent de base et ses tarifs
commerciaux sur les coûts marginaux de
lancement ariane 6 enfin il faut un
moment ou un autre qu'on s'inspire un
petit peu de ce succès ariane 6 doit
devenir le lanceur naturel
institutionnelle du marché européen dans
la gamme d'émissions lourde et moyennes
comme vega le sera pour des petites
missions il trouvera alors sa place sur
le marché commercial car c'est l'intérêt
du secteur public d'augmenter les
cadences de lancement pour répartir les
coûts fixes et pour garantir la
fiabilité du lanceur
nous serons aux côtés des industriels
pour atteindre cet objectif est
résolument aux côtés des industriels et
pour assurer le succès d'ariane 6 je
sais aussi que nous pouvons compter sur
le csg sur l'aiguillé
sur les guyanais qui ont fait de kourou
un port spatial absolument
exceptionnelle alors si il est bien
naturel qu'une partie importante des
crédits et était consacrée au
développement d'ariane 6 il est
essentiel de préparer dès aujourd'hui la
génération suivante des lanceurs la
première brique sera le moteur est
utilisable à bakou prometheus le 12
janvier 2021 le président de la
république a déjà annoncé une
accélération du programme et le cnes
fera de ces développements une priorité
quatrième en jeu autour des questions de
défense et de sécurité intérieure nous
devons faire face à une militarisation
croissante de l'espace la france doit
être en mesure de conserver sa liberté
d'accès sa liberté d'action dans
l'espace en assurant une protection et
une résilience des moyens spatiaux
critique et en décourageant et en
mettant en échec tout acteur tiers
hostile les armées doivent pouvoir
opérer directement un certain nombre
d'objets spatiaux c'est la conséquence
de mon premier point est le nouveau
commandement de l'espace s'appuyer
pourra s'appuyer sur le cnes pour monter
en compétences rapidement l'arrivée de
l'otan au centre spatial de toulouse
après celle du commandant de l'espace
traduite ailleurs l'attractivité
exceptionnelle du site
les nouvelles applications de défense
sont nombreuses et font l'objet de
programmes de recherche et de
développement technologique
le cnes a naturellement vocation à
appuyer la dgr sur l'ensemble de ces
questions
pour résumer la ministre des armées a
défini une stratégie spatiale de défense
en 2019 à la demande du président de la
république et la mise en oeuvre de cette
stratégie sera une priorité claire
dernier point dernier enjeu renforcer le
rayonnement scientifique du cnes chère à
mon coeur les programmes scientifiques
spatiaux permettent d'observer la terre
de recueillir est observé d'analysé des
données de nourrir ainsi des modèles
pour comprendre des phénomènes physiques
complexes
ils nourrissent directement les travaux
sur le climat sur la biodiversité sur
les risques naturels sur les ressources
agricoles sur les ressources hydriques
si ces techniques spatiales sont
incontournables pour suivre et pour
comprendre la question climatique et les
changements globaux de notre planète
c'est technique nous permet aussi
d'apporter d'aborder des questions
fondamentales comme la formation du
système solaire de l'univers
l'apparition de la vie où les lois
fondamentales de la physique le cnes et
ses partenaires bénéficient d'une réelle
reconnaissance internationale il
remporte régulièrement des appels
d'offres à contribuer d appel à
contributions pour la conception
d'instruments sur des missions spatiales
je pense aux six mots made in sight en
lien avec par exemple assauts dern la
caméra thème gamme de curiosity avec les
laboratoires de toulouges super cannes
pour persévérance et c'est la
programmation scientifique du cnes est
déterminante pour le rayonnement de très
nombreuses disciplines scientifiques
mais aussi nous l'avons vu pour l'avenir
de notre planète
cette programmation s'appuie sur des
séminaires de prospective scientifique
et sur un comité des programmes
les scientifiques prépare l'avenir sur
un temps long il priorise les programmes
ce mode de fonctionnement très
respectueux des temps et des priorités
de la science a fait preuve de son
efficacité doit être vraiment préserver
jeu au-delà de ces cinq ans je crois
qu'il est important de rappeler que la
stratégie française ne peut se concevoir
que dans le cadre général incluant nos
partenaires allemands et italiens les a
élus aux la relation avec nos grands
voisins ne doit pas se limiter aux
lanceurs mais doit être tournée vers la
data vers les télécoms vers le cloud
spatiale et vers l'observation
je crois enfin et c'est un point je
crois vraiment très important qu'une
constellation européenne doit émerger
très rapidement elle fournira de
l'internet haut débit partout et
contribuera à notre autonomie
stratégique
elle sera aussi l'occasion de lancer un
modèle intégré satellite lanceur usage
je veux terminer en vous re disant ma
foi dans la science et dans ces progrès
qui facilite la vie des hommes et des
femmes de notre planète l'espace il
contribue grandement d'abord à travers
les innombrables applications qui
changent notre vie au quotidien qu'on ne
voit pas forcément mais qui changent
notre quotidien mais aussi et surtout à
travers la surveillance et la bonne
santé de notre planète
l'espace apporte aussi sa part de rêve à
notre humanité et notamment à sa
jeunesse qui vit une période difficile
je rappelle que le cnes mène depuis près
de 60 ans une politique de l'éducation
et de la diffusion de la culture
scientifique remarquable que chacun des
présidents du cnes a eu à coeur de
renforcer j'en serai le continuateur si
vous voulez bien confié
ma nomination le 22 avril prochain un
autre astronaute charismatique thomas
pesquet s'envolera par la station
spatiale internationale
ce sera un grand moment pour notre pays
un moment de reprise de confiance en son
avenir aussi n'oublions pas deux autres
événements majeurs pour 2021 l'envoi de
l'extraordinaire télescope james webb
par ariane 5 et la célébration en
septembre en décembre par nom des 60 ans
du cnes ce sera l'occasion de rendre
hommage au visionnaire aux scientifiques
aux ingénieurs ou techniciens et à tous
ceux qui ont fait de la france une
grande puissance spatiale ses 60 ans
seront aussi l'occasion de préparer les
60 prochaines années évidemment du ps et
du spatial avec leur rupture
technologique élan vie de nos
concitoyens d'aller encore plus loin
dans la connaissance tant de notre
planète que d'autres notre univers voilà
je vous remercie madame la présidente je
suis évidemment prêt à répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions prendre la
wii merci beaucoup pour cet ces propos
me liminaire je vais donc laisser
maintenant mes collègues poser des
questions comment sont pas anne
catherine loisier et ensuite franck
montaugé
merci merci messieurs merci madame la
présidente
mais moi j'aurai deux questions qui
tiendront plus à l'ordre militaire on
février 2021 l'otan a commencé
annoncé en tout cas qu'à un centre
d'excellence en matière spatiale serait
basé à toulouse donc à proximité des
locaux du cnes et du commandement de
l'espace et qu'il devrait être
opérationnel pour 2025
donc quel sera selon vous le rôle du
cnes vis-à-vis de ce centre d'excellence
de quelle manière le cnes portera-t-il
les relations
des projets au sein de l'otan et la
deuxième question là aussi de teneur et
militaires en mars 2021
la france a réalisé son premier exercice
militaire dans l'espace dans le cadre
d'une opération astérix quel regard
portez vous donc sur cet exercice inédit
sur la capacité de la france à assurer
une présence militaire crédible dans
l'espace
et selon vous à quelles conditions et
qu'elles sont finalement les menaces et
les opportunités
merci merci beaucoup anne catherine la
parole est à franck montaugé ensuite
jean pierre moga
il jean franck n'est pas la peau alors
on va passer la parole à jean pierre
moga suite bernard buick est en visio je
crois merci madame la présidente bonjour
monsieur baptiste j'aurais de questions
assez courtes à vous poser la première
vous avez derrière vous une formation et
une carrière scientifique qui est
importante et je crois que c'est une
bonne chose pensez vous que le gneiss
dispose aujourd'hui des ressources
financières suffisantes pour mener une
politique de recherche ambitieuse avez
vous la volonté et les moyens de
renforcer le positionnement du business
en matière de recherche scientifique
deuxièmement en matière spatiale les
domaines de recherche sont infinies mais
les ressources sont je pense limiter
autrement dit il y a des choix à opérer
en matière de recherche
vous nous avez présenté quelques axes a
fait quelques as les as les axes
stratégiques du business que et de la
recherche selon vous quels sont les
grands domaines de recherche
scientifique qui devraient recevoir un
soutien financier du cnes et au
contraire est-ce que des domaines de
recherche et des programmes de
coopération scientifique mériterait je
dirais malheureusement d'être abandonné
les budgets étant toujours contraire je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup jean-pierre la parole en
visio la fin vous tordez tandil coup
monsieur baptiste bernard but en visio
fin
merci madame la présidente
bonjour à toutes et à tous baptiste
pourriez vous nous préciser comment les
secteurs civil et militaire pourrait
mieux se coordonner et garantir à la
france une plus grande souveraineté
spatiale quelles actions pourriez vous
menez merci merci bernard ensuite
viviane artigalas
puis daniel grémillet moi j'ai su c'est
bon merci madame la présidente
les collectivités locales s'engagent
donc des projets numériques pour
développer leur économie et maintenir
des services notamment dans les
territoires ruraux des projets de y
forer e-tourisme y médecine voit le jour
dans mon département un camion de telle
team télé imagerie médicale sillonne le
département pour la vaccination mais
peut aussi faire des des images de
radiologie d'autres examens par via le
satellite
quelle est votre stratégie de recherche
de nouvelles applications spatiales pour
accompagner les innovations des
territoires dans ces domaines
particulièrement jouffre merci merci
viviane daniel grémillet ensuite eveline
rono garabédian représente chaque
collègue monsieur baptiste une question
toute simple
aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup écouté vos
propos sur on lance on lance ma question
c'est comment allons-nous et quelle sont
vos idées pour gérer la poubelle
spatiale en clair tout a une fin de vie
on lance comment gère-t-on effectivement
la famille merci daniel levin renault
garabédian ensuite sylviane noël
présidente monsieur baptiste le centre
national a noué des partenariats avec
les institutions publiques françaises
qui sont en charge du développement type
à sd ou l'institut national pour le
développement
comment l'utilisation du spatial
s'intègre utile dans les dispositifs d
aide au développement
et savez vous quels sont les pays qui
ont pu bénéficier de ces coopérations
merci merci evelyne sylviane de noël
merci madame la présidente monsieur je
souhaiterais savoir quelle est votre
stratégie pour soutenir les 86 mille
emplois issus des filières de la sous
traitance dans la filière aéronautique
aero spéciale merci je ne vois pas
d'autres questions dont j'ai juste
j'ai pas mal mais précise juste vous
relancez peut-être sur une des
préoccupations j'exprimais qui est en
quoi le cnes peut permettre de retrouver
une coopération européenne plus soutenu
plus ambitieuse et surtout plus communes
c'est à éviter que les allemands partent
dans leur coin que les italiens partent
dans leur coin avec vega fin bon voilà
que comment est ce qu'on peut remettre
du liant avec en quoi le cnes voilà peux
aider je vous laisse répondre à cette
première série de questions et je dis à
mes collègues n'hésitez pas si merci
beaucoup
peut-être pour répondre immédiatement à
s'être enfin à cette question où en
toute la donne et des premiers éléments
de réponse donc effectivement on voit
bien qu'il ya une complétude à une
concurrence internationale qui est
extrêmement forte
aujourd'hui mais qu' il n'y a aussi un
certain nombre de questions qui sont des
questions au sein de l'union européenne
voilà de nouveaux acteurs qui veulent
émerger
je crois que nos partenaires allemands
veulent en particulier sont très
attachés à l'idée de faire un micro
lanceur rapidement je moi je
je pense que il faut c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'il faut regarder avec eux
et éventuellement les aider sur un
certain nombre de points en disposant
d'un savoir faire qui est absolument qui
est absolument remarquable et qu'il faut
plutôt de voir une logique trop trop
d'opposition moi je pense que bien au
contraire il faut travailler avec nos
collègues nos collègues allemands et
regarder comment est-ce qu'on peut
travailler sur un micro lanceur qui
pourrait devenir à un moment donné un
micro lanceur européen est ce que ce
sera un projet allemand ou est ce que ce
sera un autre projet je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas l'idée d'avoir un micro
lanceur à un moment donné européen qui
soit efficace et à bas coût
et bien c'est quelque chose c'est un
projet qui est quelque chose qui est
quelque chose d'intéressant
bon au delà évidemment
on dispose je crois aujourd'hui d'une
gamme de lanceurs qui est déjà complète
qui est déjà très complète en europe
on a parlé de dégâts on parle d'art
gagnent 6 aujourd'hui
moi je crois que la vraie question dans
les années qui viennent ça va être une
question comme je le disais dans mes
propos liminaire à quel point est ce
qu'on est capable d'avoir des lancements
institutionnels suffisant qu'ils vont
être capables de nous qu'ils vont nous
permettre de mener une politique
commerciale qui a une politique très
violent commercial suffisamment robuste
pour faire face aux dérives très très
bas qui sont en train de qui sont en
train d'arriver
outre atlantique et donc cette question
là c'est une question qui est crucial je
crois que de toute façon l'europe a
besoin a lancé un lanceur lourd pour
avoir un accès et une autonomie à
laisser un accès autonome à l'espace
c'est quelque chose qui est absolument
centrale je crois pour la stratégie de
tous les états de souveraineté donc il
faut apprendre à un moment ou un autre
nous en donner les moyens
derrière jeudi pour dire les choses de
manière peut-être plus positive encore
le fait que l'ensemble des états
européens aujourd'hui s'intéressent
beaucoup à l'espace c'est quand même
quelque chose qui montre bien que c'est
un domaine qui est absolument crucial
aujourd'hui et
je trouve que c'est il faut s'en
féliciter c'est une bonne nouvelle
maintenant on a un enjeu qui est un
enjeu de coordination si on doit parler
à un moment donné de la manière dont ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui en particulier
pour le développement de grands
programmes à travers les a on voit bien
qu'une des difficultés ou une des
questions qui peut se poser c'est la
question du retour géographique et de la
complexité qu'on peut avoir qui indique
induisent question du retour
géographique sur l'organisation de la
production d'un lanceur seule
organisation industrielle
c'est sans doute des choses sur
lesquelles il faut qu'on puisse
réfléchir pour arriver à des choses plus
intelligentes et plus souple que les
règles qui sont aujourd'hui en place
autant la règle du retour géographique
sur des grands programmes scientifiques
très risqué ou ne ne posent pas
véritablement me semble tout à fait
naturel est absolument ne pose aucune
difficulté
autant effectivement si on veut faire un
certain nombre d'objets en meurent en
moyenne ou en grandes séries qui sont
très compétitifs
on voit bien que cette question-là
risque à un moment donné d'être d'être
extrêmement d'être compliqué ça c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué aujourd'hui
donc voilà ça c'est sans doute un enjeu
majeur après toujours je ne veux pas
être trop long mais il faut qu'on se
mobilisent ensemble avec nos partenaires
européens sur un ou deux grands nouveaux
projets et grandes ambitions pour
l'espace je crois que très clairement
que la constellation
c'est un grand sujet ce qui me permet
aussi de répondre un certain nombre de
sujets qui ont été levées à travers les
questions
une constellation européenne c'est un
moyen d'accès avec un internet haut
débit sur l'ensemble des territoires
l'ensemble du l'ensemble de la planète
donc y compris nos territoires qui sont
éventuellement mal connectés aujourd'hui
ou difficilement connectés donc c'est
c'est vraiment un enjeu stratégique
majeur pour l'europe aujourd'hui
il faut qu'on y aille au delà de cette
question là au delà des au delà des
constellations je pense qu elle aussi
évidemment un enjeu sur le prochain
lanceur qui doit être conçue dans un
cadre européen efficace et rationnelle
peut-être si je reprends les questions
en lit on dans les groupes un petit peu
sur les questions autour de
l'articulation entre le cnes et les
activités de défense
jeu bon l'arrivée de l'otan et du cdo
sur le campus de toulouse c'est une
opportunité fabuleuse sa montre ça
montre avant tout l'attractivité
extrêmement forte du site et le
savoir-faire en fait du site
toulouse c'est extraordinaire non
seulement grâce au centre
enfin grâce au cnes qui est présent mais
est loin de moi l'idée de me laisser le
le centre de lutèce mais au delà du cnes
il ya tout l'écosystème qui est autour
et qui est présent sur le site
et donc c'est ce qui fait en fait de ce
qui fait d'eux du site et de la région
un endroit absolument exceptionnel et
c'est l'attractivité et c'est cette
attractivité qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
a effectivement l'otan et le
commandement de l'espace qui s'installe
sur le campus du plein alors s'installer
sur le campus ça veut dire que le
directement on va pouvoir bénéficier de
coopérations qui sont des coopération
rapprochée des changes en permanence sur
ces sujets là et on a aujourd'hui
évidemment un transfert de savoir faire
là je parle du commandement de l'espace
entre les équipes du cnes et les équipes
du c d e qui je crois transfert qui se
fait de ce qui se fait très bien et de
manière extrêmement fluide aujourd'hui
sur la meilleure coordination toujours
sur la ste les dimensions de défense
meilleure coordination militaire un
nombre très significatif d'applications
spatiales ont évidemment une dimension
dual c'est évident et c'est vrai aussi
dans toutes les applications numériques
qui sont en train d'émerger comme usage
donc vraiment c'est cette dualité elle
et elle est constante
je crois que les relations avec la dg a
là aussi sont très sont à la fois très
fluide et très efficace je crois que la
dg a tient enfin je ne veux pas parler à
la place du dg a mais je crois que il ya
une volonté d'avoir un cnes qui conserve
une compétence technique extrêmement
forte pour être capable d'être un
interlocuteur est d'être une aide sur
l'ensemble des questions qui tout ce qui
touche au sens patio est donc cette
coordination se fait bien je tiens aussi
à dire que le fait qu'on ait une feuille
de route qu'ils soient une feuille de
route stratégique
de la france sur la sur la défense
spatial c'est aussi quelque chose qui
simplifie considérablement notre
coordination et la manière de travailler
avec l'ensemble des acteurs et je crois
que ça c'est vraiment un modèle dont on
voit assez inspiré tout être sur
l'ensemble des champs est-ce que ça
permet évidemment d'avoir une vision
très claire pour les opérateurs dont le
cnes évidemment sur la manière dont tu
dois travailler peut-être toujours vous
m'excusez peut-être un petit peu dans le
désordre dans la prise de réponse aux
questions sur la fin de vie des
satellites donc on a évidemment un enjeu
nous avons de plus en plus d'objets qui
sont aujourd'hui en orbite et le temps
normal de désorbitation suivant les
types de le type de le type de rebif
peut être peut être vraiment longs et
donc effectivement on a une forme
d'encombrement aujourd'hui alors loin de
moi du tout l'idée le moi l'idée de
minorer ce problème si on parle de
collisions ou de choses comme ça
aujourd'hui
le nombre de collisions avérés dans le
monde d'objets en orbite est
relativement modeste quelques unités je
crois qu'ils sont qui sont qui sont
avérées aujourd'hui donc c'est pas c'est
pas quelque chose de c'est pas tous les
jours mais maintenant évidemment ce le
nombre potentiel de collision on croit
bien plus vite que le nombre d'objets
qui sont qui sont qui sont en orbite et
et donc on a un véritable enjeu alors
comment est-ce qu'on doit travailler là
dessus je veux dire qu'il ya trois il ya
trois grands sujets le premier sujet
c'est d'alors capable de d'identifier
l'ensemble des débris qui sont
aujourd'hui en orbite savoir où il sont
les monitorer les suivre avec différents
types de technologies soient de
l'optique soit du radar etc
donc ça veut dire en fait suivi
permanent de l'ensemble des débris qui
sont qui sont en orbite ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est de
concevoir aussi des satellites qui
demain sont capables de ceux désorientés
plus rapidement ou ne produisent pas
trop de débris et donc ça c'est un
ensemble de sujets qui sont déjà regardé
à travers la loi spéciale aujourd'hui et
puis dans les autres pays en particulier
aux etats-unis c'est aussi quelque chose
qui est très très regardé et puis là le
troisième moyen qui est un moyen le plus
immédiat c'est comment est ce qu'on fait
pour traiter les débris qui sont
aujourd'hui en orbite et donc comment
est ce qu'on va faire pour les pour les
désorbiter donc il ya un ensemble de
deux sujets qui sont un ensemble de
techniques qui sont mises en oeuvre
aujourd'hui pour essayer de pour essayer
de les désorbiter sachant qu évidemment
l'objectif c'est essayer de ne pas se
retrouver avec plus de débris qu'on en a
quand on essaye de faire des orbites et
un satellite
cette question de fin de vie les
satellites et d'encombrement de l'espace
évidemment il faut il faut la regarder
aussi en pensant que on va bientôt avoir
des constellations de satellites qui
vont arriver et des constellations une
constellation ce sont au minimum
quelques centaines de satellites
jusqu'à quelques mini et donc on voit
bien que c'est le temps qu'ont brement
qu'on a aujourd'hui
il va ne faire que croître donc
aujourd'hui elon musk quand ils ans
il est lens par 60 donc c'est 60 à
chaque lancement pour sa constellation
donc c'est voilà donc on a on a on a
évidemment cette question qui est
absolument centrale sa demande avant
tout aussi un effet un immense effort de
coordination internationale sur ce sujet
là sur les questions de sur les
questions peut-être de développement le
lilas en fait on va de nouveau toucher
aux questions qui sont absolument
central des questions de l'observation
de la terre l'eau en fait tous les
modèles aujourd'hui qui nous permettent
de comprendre ce qui se passe quand deux
qui permettent aux scientifiques de
comprendre aujourd'hui comment notre
comment notre planète fonctionne enfin
qu'elle est aussi bien sur des questions
de météo sur des crises nos climats sur
des questions de suivi de notre
production agricole sur des questions de
de pandémie alors peut-être pas le vide
mais sur d'autres d'autres types de
pandémie etc
ce sont des modèles qui sont des modèles
mathématiques ou numérique mais qui sont
systématiquement n'y vit aujourd'hui de
données spatiales
ces données spatiales elles sont
cruciales c'est à dire que si vous les
enlevez les modèles derrière mais en
fait ne ne fonctionne plus ne tourne
plus donc vraiment l'apport du spatial
pour la compréhension de la vie pour la
compréhension des phénomènes qui sont
des phénomènes physiques qui gouvernent
nos vies sur sur terre sont c'est
vraiment absolument crucial et c'est
évidemment le cas dans le monde du
développement en particulier sur les
questions de ressources agricoles et de
ressources hydriques qui sont des points
cruciaux pour les questions pour un
certain nombre de pays de pays du sud
et c'est vrai aussi pour le suivi des
populations pour le suivi des pollutions
donc c'est vraiment on est on est
vraiment au coeur des applications
spatiales et on est au coeur de la
coopération entre différents
les organismes en france et dans le
monde je ça me permet peut-être de
répondre aux questions de aux questions
de sciences sur les priorités
alors je pense que c'est un
indirectement la question qui est posée
est une question enfin c'est une
question qui est très difficile parce
que c'est la question du choix des
priorités scientifiques pour l'avenir et
je pense qu'il faut être
il faut être très modeste quand on quand
on aborde ces questions parce que c'est
des questions qui sont très complexes
sur des tanks qui sont très long et il
faut vraiment être à l'écouté des
scientifiques 1 c'est ce que j'ai essayé
de deux j'ai essayé d'insister
lourdement sur ce point dans mon
introduction
si on regarde les très grands champs
aujourd'hui moi je crois qu'il ya une
priorité que nous devons pousser c'est
la priorité
vous l'avez compris j'en ai parlé
plusieurs fois c'est c'est tout ce qui
touche au tour de la question de
l'observation de la terre parce que
pourquoi parce que on a derrière des
questions qui sont des questions
urgentes et des questions qui mobilise
l'ensemble de nos sociétés aujourd'hui
autour des questions du climat autour
des questions de la biodiversité autour
des questions du chili des pollutions
donc ces sujets là me semble-t-il sont
absolument sans fin sont vraiment sont
vraiment cruciaux et et je crois
vraiment d'ailleurs qu'on verra le
nombre le nombre de données qui arrive
sur c'est sur ces questions là ne fait
que croître
comme dans d'autres champs je suis
persuadé aussi qu'on a avec la
miniaturisation des satellites les
petits lanceurs de satellites etc
on va avoir une profusion de données qui
vont arriver et c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'il me semble être une
priorité aujourd'hui pour le pour la
suite après évidemment la question de la
compréhension de
l'univers la compréhension des origines
de nos origines
ces sont des choses qui nous font qui
nous touche tous nos très profondément
et là aussi on a des programmes qui sont
déjà très organisée et je pense qu'il
faut qu'on suive sur ces sujets là la
question naturelle qui se pose après et
qu'on a peut-être incidemment abordés à
travers la question c'est la question de
l'exploration humaine et de l'espace
faut avoir en tête que comme vous le
savez l'europe ça n'a pas été
historiquement une des très très grande
priorité de l'europe les états unis
[Musique]
l'urss puis la russie on en fait des
priorités qui sont beaucoup plus fortes
technologiquement il ya des choses qu'on
sait qu'on qu'on peut faire évidemment
faut avoir en tête que les coûts sont
évidemment absolument façon très
significatif
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de budget
pendant pendant sept
cette discussion il faut avoir en tête
que le budget spatial européen consolidé
par rapport à celui des états-unis par
par habitant on est presque un ordre de
grandeur de différence donc c'est quand
même très très significatif donc il faut
enfin voilà il faut tenir tout ça vous
faut vous faut conserver cette équation
global un scientifique pur vous dirais
que la priorité c'est l'observance et
c'est d'utiliser des sondes ou
d'utiliser des satellites pour faire de
l'observation pour comprendre des
phénomènes et c'est pas l'exploration
s'est passé pas forcément directement
l'exploit envoyer des hommes dans
l'espace
l'ingénieur ou vous dirai ça aurait sans
doute un point de vue un petit peu
différent en vous disant qu évidemment
c'est un formidable défi technologique
de faire ça et évidemment l'homme et le
citoyen
ne peut que rêver en imaginant comme
vous tous que demain on pourrait
effectivement être sur la lune de
manière durable ou même un peu plus long
terme
envoyez envoyer des hommes sur mars nous
n'oublions ouais c'est évidemment c'est
évidemment un défi absolument essayer
d'emmener un défi absolument
extraordinaire je crois profondément en
fait que c'est sur ces deux derniers
points
là aussi il faut essayer de dépasser
on voit bien qu'il ya un certain nombre
de grands pays qui se positionne
aujourd'hui pour envoyer pour pourquoi
ce une base durablement sur la lune ou
pour envoyer des hommes sur mars demain
je veux rêver un instant et dire que
c'est quand même un défi international
avant tout contenu des moyens et la
technologie qu'il faut développer pour
faire ces choses là il serait quand même
rêvons un instant il faisons un grand
projet international jeu un enjeu un
point essentiel aussi sur qui a été
soulevée sur la question des emplois
dans la filière dans la filière spatiale
bon je pense qu'il ya ya comme je les
mentionnaient dans mon exposé il ya un
certain nombre de secteurs qui vont qui
vont bien qu'ils vont même très très
bien dans le coup on a des champions
internationaux qui sont qui sont des
champions français ou européens
d'autres secteurs où évidemment il ya
plus de questions sur la question je
vais pas revenir sur la question des
lanceurs mais c'est mais c'est
évidemment c'est évidemment un sujet le
cnes est là pour pour garantir à la fois
du transfert de technologie de l'apport
de technologies pour garantir des
programmes de pour garantir des
programmes aux industriels pour les
faire monter en compétences en
permanence et c'est ça et c'est ça notre
c'est ça notre rôle parce que la
compétitivité de la filière passe par là
et les emplois passent par cette
compétitivité
donc je crois vraiment que c'est
absolument essentiel qu'on soit
mobilisée sur ces questions voilà
je crois avoir répondu sur la question
du numérique et du territoire
incidemment à travers le à travers la
question de à travers la question de sur
les constellations
je redis encore une fois que je moi je
j'en crois mon projet évidemment
durablement à la frontière entre le
numérique et le spatial et le fait que
je vienne du monde du numérique aussi
probablement un petit peu pour elle de
jouer très très bien je propose à franck
montaugé qui voilà qui est arrivé de
poser les questions qu'il avait ses
d'autres collègues pour nathan m merci
madame la présidente monsieur philippe
bonjour j'aurais une question un peu
particulier à vous poser donc le laisse
passer le quatrième je dirais lieu de
lieux d'affrontements ou de coopération
selon don qu'il ya derrière cette
question de l'occupation de l'espace des
enjeux des enjeux stratégiques des
enjeux de souveraineté pour pour chaque
état pour chaque état je voudrais savoir
quelle est votre votre réflexion sur
l'état du droit international de
l'espace et si dans votre projet vous
avez des propositions
justement pour faire évoluer ce droit
international de l'espace vert +2 de
coopération la question des déchets qui
a été évoquée étant un des sujets de ce
droit international mais n'est pas le
seul
voilà on a l'impression quand on n'est
pas spécialiste et c'est mon cas qui a
une forme de jeunes aujourd'hui et que
c'est un peu comme on dit chez moi au
plus fort la guirlande
donc donc ça ça ça pose quand même ça
pose quand même un problème tout à fait
tout à fait important donc j'aurais
voulu savoir si dans votre projet au nom
du disque est du cnes le cas échéant si
vous êtes retenu vous aurez des
propositions à faire et comment le cnes
donc va se positionner dans ces
discussions
par l'entremise du gouvernement français
ou des autorités européennes pour
justement se faire entendre dans les
instances internationales dans ce
domaine là je vous remercie
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres questions mes
chers collègues je n'en vois pas à leur
permettez moi de vous imposer une
dernière de vous relancer
monsieur bâti sur une question qui vous
est posée au début en coin vous êtes
meilleurs que les autres en quoi votre
expérience par ailleurs en quoi votre
moins d'expérience que d'autres dans le
spatial
peut être un atout pour le cnes pardon à
la cc oui donc peut-être pour commencer
par sur la question sur le l'espace lieu
le lieu d'affrontements lieu de
concurrence enjeu de souveraineté
oui oui bien entendu on voit bien que
aujourd'hui il ya un certain nombre de
règles ou de régulation internationale
mais qui sont encore relativement
relativement limité la question c'est
effectivement comment est ce qu'on fait
émerger un ensemble de droits ou un
ensemble de régulations qui vont nous
permettre de faire vivre ensemble un
grand nombre d'objets spatiaux ces
questions elle se pose pour les débris
elle se pose pour des choses très
concrètes c'est comment est-ce que deux
satellites qui sont en train d'avoir une
fin qui si on ne sait rien vont se
rencontrer comment est ce qu'on fait
pour lequel va céder la priorité à
l'autre lequel va bouger la même
question qu'on a aujourd'hui pour les
questions contrôle aérien ce va se poser
demain pour les questions pour les
questions spatiales
et c'est vrai aussi pour la question de
l'attribution de fréquences attributions
ses 16 ans et jean violas sont encore je
crois relativement belle mission et là
en plus la multiplicité des acteurs
aujourd'hui c'est que on a quand même
une grande difficulté à construire
quelque chose durablement sur sur ce
sujet c'est un enjeu majeur pour quoi je
suis relativement optimiste parce qu'en
fait c'est l'enjeu est tel est l'enjeu
est tellement important que les acteurs
ont tous intérêt à poser un minimum de
fondement je trouve que l'exemple du
trafic aérien est un assez bonne c'est
vrai exemple y compris y compris dans
des conditions pendant la guerre froide
par exemple où les relations n'étaient
pas forcément les plus simples ça nous a
pas empêché de développer des systèmes
de contrôle aériens internationaux qui
étaient relativement robuste donc je
pense que ces questions là de toute
façon vont émerger parce que elles sont
consubstantielles au développement du
nombre d'objets spatiaux aujourd'hui
dans l'espace sur sur la question
délicate madame la présidente j'avais
oublié d'y répondre je ne sais pas
pourquoi
non alors évidemment je je je je ne sais
pas une famille ça c'est pas à moi de me
prononcer évidemment sur les autres
candidatures mais j'ai eu effectivement
des noms de gens que je connais
d'ailleurs par ailleurs qui sont des
gens très bien qui était qui était
effectivement supputer être candidat je
crois que
je crois que j'ai une expérience
industrielle
j'ai une expérience de recherche et de
direction de grands organismes de
recherche et que le fait que je vienne
du numérique avec les questions et les
enjeux qui sont à la croque au
croisement entre le monde du numérique
et le monde du spatial mais me donne une
allure une couleur si je peux me
permettre
qui peut être intéressant pour
aujourd'hui pour le cnes et c'est vrai
non seulement pour le monde aval
c'est-à-dire pour tous les nouveaux
enjeux les nouveaux services du spatial
qui sont en train d'arriver
mais c'est vrai aussi pour les questions
pour la manière dont on conçoit
aujourd'hui l'innovation l'industrie au
sein au sein du spatial moi j'ai vu la
révolution numérique sur un certain
nombre de secteurs
je sais qu'elle peut être à la fois sa
force c'est presque sa violence et je
vois là et je pense pouvoir contribuer
utilement à préparer non seulement le
cnes mais au delà du cnes l'ensemble des
acteurs de la filière spatiale en france
et en europe sur le sujet vous aviez
mentionné tout au début peut-être pour
pour épandre complètement cette fois ci
à toutes les questions
vous avez mentionné le fait que les
ministres pouvaient ne pas ne pas être
en accord
je peux le dire on parle pas répondre à
cette question là mais mais par contre
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'ils
évidemment j'ai vu tous les ministres
qui étaient qui étaient concernés par le
sujet du spatial et je peux vous dire
que tout cas sur le projet et sur les
grands enjeux
demain pour le pour le spatial en france
et en europe
je n'ai pas vu
je n'ai pas vu de différence
fondamentale du tout de perception de
ces enjeux et des grandes priorités pour
demain donc très bien merci beaucoup y
at il d'autres questions des yeux dans
le dos donc non je n'en vois pas il me
reste à vous remercier et demander à mes
collègues bien sûr de rester pour que
nous procédions vote
merci puis il bien bonne audition à
l'assemblée nationale puisque c'est
l'exercice qui suit
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]